[Music]
it is time again to return to the
olympians
as there are several still left to cover
today's video will be dedicated to the
queen of olympus herself
hera as one of the original
six olympians hera was the daughter of
the titans
cronus and reya the four main domains of
hera
include women childbirth
family and most ironically
marriage because it is rather strange
that the goddess of marriage would spend
such a
large portion of time seeking revenge
against the
many lovers and illegitimate children of
her husband
but you'll soon learn that jealousy and
the desire for vengeance were two of
hera's defining characteristics
being married to zoo certainly would
have come with its own
challenges but it also meant that hera
ruled olympus
as the queen of gods you often see her
portrayed as a
beautiful woman wearing a crown with a
lotus tip scepter
sitting on her throne accompanied by a
variety of her favorite sacred animals
which include the peacock the lion
the hawk and the cuckoo bird
compared to her sisters demeter and
hestia
hera plays a very large part in greek
mythology
not just in terms of her cult and
worship but also in the dozens of
stories she appeared in
one of the things you may not have read
about is hera's deep
hatred for large and bulky wallets
luckily for all of us today's video is
sponsored by ridge
the ridge wallet's compact and sleek
design means it can hold your cards and
cash
but still easily fit into your pocket
they come in a variety of different
designs and colors
and ridge are so confident that you will
love their wallets
they even give you a free 45-day
money-back guarantee
go to ridge.com mythology to get 10
percent of your order today
that's ridge.com mythology
not only does it support the channel it
also appeases hera
and trust me you do not want to be on
her bad side
[Music]
let's start with the story of how zeus
and hera became
husband and wife or what is commonly
referred to
as the seduction of hera when zeus first
proposed marriage hera declined his
offer
but as we know with zeus persistence is
key
he then decided to use hera's love and
empathy for animals to his
own advantage zeus conjured up a
terrible
storm and transformed himself into a
cuckoo bird
when hera came across the tiny
frightened bird
she embraced it and kept it warm
zeus then transformed back to himself
and revealed this was all part of his
plan to convince her to marry him
for whatever reason this worked and the
first
olympian wedding would take place the
wedding itself was a large and
prestigious event
with gifts being showered upon hera from
all across the land
her grandmother gaia gave her an entire
garden
filled with golden apples which would be
looked after by the hesperides and
guarded by the serpent ladon
many of the greek islands and states
claim that the wedding took place on
their land
as hosting such a prestigious event
could only bring
good fortune it also became tradition
for those
native to these lands to honour this day
every year with a
sacrifice as with most deities there is
always an interest in their children
and hera had numerous children zeus
being the father of most
with some rather weird exceptions the
most well-known of these children who
needs very little introduction
is ares the god of war and the resident
hothead of olympus similar to ares you
have
enyo a goddess of war who would be seen
by the side of ares whenever a
city was sacked or destroyed according
to homer
eris and enyo were very similar if not
the same
individual however hessia disagrees
believing
eris was instead the daughter of nyx
hephaestus certainly falls into the
weird category
jealous of zeus giving birth to athena
without her hera tried to do the same
hephaestus however wasn't the perfect
specimen that athena was
hera found herself repulsed by his
deformities
and so when he was born poor baby
hephaestus was
yeasted off mount olympus and left to
fend for himself
there are some accounts that suggest
that this may have happened again
with the goddess of youth [ __ ] most
commonly described as the daughter of
hera
and zeus there are some rare versions
where she was born
after hera consumed a magical piece of
lettuce
some other children worthy of a mention
include the goddess of childbirth
elephia and the personification of
liberty
eletheria one of the first stories i
remember hera being mentioned in
is in the argonautica the story of jason
and the argonauts here she appears to
jason in disguise
in order to set in motion a chain of
events that would eventually lead to
jason's quest for the golden fleece
and the attempt to reclaim his kingdom
however hera's motivation in this story
is not just to help jason because it's
the right thing to do
it's more so revenge or justice against
king peleus the king had murdered his
grandmother in one of hera's temples
jason and peleus were destined to cross
paths eventually
and so hera sped up this process and
convinced jason and medea to kill the
king who stood in their way
some of the most well-known stories of
hera involved greek mythology's most
iconic hero heracles whose name
ironically means glory of hera
despite his name hera despised heracles
which probably had more to do with zeus
than heracles himself
when zeus heard of alcamini's pregnancy
he announced to all the gods that on
this particular date
a child of zeus would be born who would
rule all those around him
hera had zeus were an oath to this claim
and so began
her hatred of heracles when that day
finally came
she visited stenelus the son of perseus
whose wife was due to have a child in
two months time
but as the goddess of childbirth she
made the birth happen
on that day she then visited alcamini
and delayed the birth of heracles
meaning zeus's oath would be honoured
and the prophecy he made would refer to
eurystheus the great grandson of zeus as
opposed to heracles
whilst heracles was still a baby hera
sent two snakes into the boy's bed
chamber to kill him
while he was sleeping to her surprise
heracles was found the next morning
joyfully waving around the two snakes he
had strangled
when heracles came of age and started
his own family
hera drove him into a state of madness
where he murdered
said family in order to redeem himself
he would have to complete his labors
which coincidentally were chosen by hera
and
king eurystheus labours they thought
would finally
kill heracles but they were wrong
heracles would eventually die but it
wasn't at the hands of hera
he would then also become a permanent
resident on olympus
so i guess you could say heracles had
the last
laugh hera also played a large role in
the events that led to the trojan war
this story begins with the nymph thetis
more commonly known as the mother of
achilles
thetis was to marry king peleus a union
advised by
zeus all the gods and goddesses were to
attend this wedding and
each bring a gift the only deity to be
declined
entry was eris the goddess of discord
and strife when hermes turned her away
as
zeus ordered she was furious
she had brought with her a golden apple
with the inscription
to the fairest after being denied entry
she
threw the apple into the room where the
ceremony was taking place
athena aphrodite and hera all looked
down at the apple
and claimed it belonged to them and so
began a dispute as to which of the three
goddesses was the most
beautiful as there was no agreement in
sight
they took this dispute to zeus who
wisely decided he wanted
no part in any of this instead he passed
the buck to the trojan prince
paris all three goddesses appeared
before paris
undressed and asked him to be the judge
of this beauty contest
paris however was unable to decide and
so the three took to bribing him instead
athena offered him all the wisdom and
fame he desired
hera offered him political power an
aphrodite promised him the most
beautiful mortal woman as his bride
paris eventually chose aphrodite and the
woman promised to him was helen of
troy who already happened to be married
to the king of sparta
needless to say athena and hera were
less than pleased with paris's decision
and his eventual abduction of helen
would lead to the great trojan war
there are many small actions that led to
this war
but it's fair to say that athena hera
and aphrodite
all played a significant role
now we move on to the segment i like to
call every time
hera caught zeus with his hands in the
cookie jar and then
proceeded to blame said cookie jar we
are of course referring to the
many affairs of zeus that hera was at
least aware of
the story of io definitely falls into
the weird category
in this story hera was sure she would
catch zeus in the act this time
with a woman named io zeus however knew
hera was suspicious and before she
appeared he transformed io
into a cow in order to hide his new
mistress
hera not falling for this trick insisted
that zeus gave her this cow
as a gift she then instructed the
hundred-eyed
giant argus to stand guard whenever he
would fall asleep
half of his eyes would remain open
ensuring no one could sneak past him
zeus not wanting to intervene himself in
order to avoid
suspicion had hermes free io on his
behalf
hermes was able to send all 100 of
argus's eyes into a deep slumber
before slaying him and setting io free
to honor his service heretic argus his
eyes and placed them on her favorite
animal
the peacock the ancient greeks also used
this story as a way to explain
the eye pattern found on peacocks
when hera found out about lito being
pregnant with artemus and apollo
she made sure that as long as lito was
on the mainland
she couldn't give birth the goddess of
childbirth and her
own daughter elithia was forbidden from
offering assistance
poseidon guided leto to the island of
delos
away from the eyes of hera the other
deities distracted hera with a beautiful
necklace
long enough for elepha to slip away and
ensure both
artemis and apollo were born
dionysus is another olympian who was
almost
never born because of hera when she
discovered a woman named
emily was pregnant with the child of
zeus she disguised herself
as emily's nurse and convinced her that
unless zeus showed her his true
appearance
he did not love her this emily had zeus
swear an
oath and when he did eventually show
himself she burst into flames and died
zeus then had the unborn child sewn into
his own thigh
this child was of course dionysus
[Music]
the last story i will leave you with is
the rather puzzling case of
tyracius a prophet and priest of zeus
one day tyrussius came across two snakes
mating
he then for whatever reason took a stick
and began to beat the snakes away
for this he was transformed into a woman
and so he was now a
priestess of hera the next time she came
across snake's mating
tyracius trampled all over them and was
transformed back into a man
during an argument between zeus and hera
as to who had the most pleasure during
sex
teresias found himself in the middle
hera was adamant
that it was men and zeus that it was
women
they used tyracius as the decider
because he had experienced it from both
sides
tyracius sided with zeus hera not liking
this answer then blinded him
zeus unable to undo the actions of his
wife gave tyracius the gift of prophecy
to make up for his loss of sight
the portrayal of hera's overall
character is slightly odd
for the goddess of marriage family
childbirth
and women you'd expect a stable caring
and forgiving nature at times this may
be the case with hera but there are
plenty of occasions where she is the
exact
opposite with athena it makes sense
because you have the conflicting
accounts of the greek and roman poets
but with hera the same can't be said
an interesting explanation that i came
across which is pretty much
just an unproven theory is that hera
could predate the hellenis to a period
in ancient greece that was much more
matriarchal
when the shift to a more patriarchal
society happened
hera's attempts to challenge zeus's rule
or authority was seen in a much more
comical manner
hence the over-the-top jealousy and the
acceptance that zeus will do
whatever he wants to do this theory is
rejected by most scholars because of a
lack of evidence
if you ask me the answer is simple being
married to zeus is probably enough to
drive
anyone insane but let me know what you
think in the comment section
as always i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
you